Joel Platt on the call with that
Michigan at Wisconsin more pressure on
Michigan or Wisconsin Joel in this game
well before I get to that I just want to
point out how you guys are so wrong
about noon games Red River has always
been played at 11:00 central Michigan
Ohio State has always been played at
noon Eastern it is actually the
historical great window and that's why
we're going back to it and bringing all
of our best games at noon which is why
you're getting Michigan and Wisconsin
tomorrow at noon Eastern and it's gonna
be great
wave enjoy the big one Joel layman here
the reason why you have Michigan and
Wisconsin on at noon because you do a
pregame show and it'll lead right into
this game so let's not kid anybody the
Thanksgiving game but that's not really
are you trying to suggest a show drives
ratings for a game I would actually flip
it and say we're trying to help them out
oh wow okay I apologize Jim you're a
veteran come on Dan
you're a veteran I apologize I know you
married the two together because if you
have a pregame show you want to have a
great game to lead into and then people
to an earlier just so they can hear
Urban Meyer and you know and and we
needed to change the status quo right I
mean listen if we're gonna go out there
ESPN you know this better than anybody
the four-letter is a behemoth and they
have done a remarkable job and I would
say more in particular in the sport of
college football and anywhere else
they've kind of made the sport and
gameday is such a behemoth in the room
that you got to do something you know to
to move the needle a little bit and
that's what we've been trying to do and
that's what we're gonna try to do with
this noon slot and I hope listen I hope
people like it and the rating suggests
that early in the years that they have
it's been kind of a forgotten window
like you guys have been pointing out
tongue-in-cheek with all the basketball
schools but we're gonna return some of
those good games back to that point and
you also have the pregame show on Fox
that Reggie Bush Matt Leinart Reggie
going back to USC and tonight how about
that yeah
what kind of reception what kind of
reception do you think Reggie gets
unbelievable reception the fan base and
I live in Southern California and I live
down in kind of like Orange County and
like very heavy USC territory Reggie is
still beloved no one has ill-will even
from the school's perspective towards
Reggie it's just that the NCAA bans them
from all these events you know and and
so that connection has been severed but
him going back the bub is buzz is
palpable out there on the west coast
they need some positive traction with
that program right now and I can't tell
you what that scene tonight just tuned
in okay and I'm not here to like shill
for for tuning in or whatever but Urban
Meyer's gonna be sitting there with
Reggie Bush with everything that's going
on at USC I would tune it all right now
back to my original question more
pressure on you no question or more
pressure on North Korea on Wisconsin or
Michigan
there's absolutely more pressure on
Michigan they have this is not a team
that a lot of people expected much of
speaking of Wisconsin this year I didn't
even have my Mike's coming into the
season and they've come out and played
incredibly well on both sides of the
ball early in the game or excuse me
early in the year so Dan I think that
they're playing a little bit with house
money you know Jonathan Franklin's going
for the all-time rushing record if he
gets 19 200 more yards there's a lot of
positives with Wisconsin with Michigan
there's a lot of wringing of hands going
on is this new offense really gonna work
it hasn't looked good in the first two
weeks and trust me on film it's look
even worse than what it looked like live
so Michigan's got all the questions
surrounding them how short of elite
ilish does Shay Patterson have is Jim
Harbaugh going to get back involved into
the game plan and the play calling
because he certainly handed the keys
over to a very inexperienced
Josh Janis the offensive coordinator in
the first couple of weeks so Michigan
has has an immense amount of pressure
not even to mention that their own six
under Harbaugh as underdogs you know you
got to start winning some of these games
in particular on the road which they
haven't been able to do you've forgotten
more football than I know but it's a
Jonathan Taylor you were talking about
the running
no Jonathan Franklin I said Jonathan
Franklin did not you see I started
thinking about Los Angeles and Jonathan
Franklin was the old UCLA back well yes
that's right that's right
good good recover there Joe does Notre
Dame have no chance against Georgia I
think that the gap is fairly wide right
now but it's it's going to be
exaggerated by the pundits because I do
think Georgia beats them pretty handily
but I think it's only because of the
specific matchup Notre Dame struggles
defending the run they have in their
first two games they've missed more
tackles than anyone would want them to
miss and Georgia is one of the best
rushing teams in the entire country in
fact they're rushing the ball for over
286 yards per game so with the Andre
Swift in the backfield and his ability
to make people miss in space I just
think that the matchup it's terrible for
Notre Dame but it will be trust me when
they win let's say Georgia wins by two
scores three scores Dan let's call it 20
yeah I it's gonna be exaggerated
everyone gonna be like see Notre Dame is
trash and the SEC is the strongest thing
since you know peanut butter and jelly
or whatever they say and and that's I
think exaggerated I think specifically
this matchup is really poor for Notre
Dame however yeah but when people say
somebody has no chance that has come
back to bite people it's naive to say
somebody has no chance I know the
dolphins and the Jets probably have no
chance but they do have a chance because
they're on the field against these teams
and Georgia has a chance against Georgia
I are Notre Dame has a chance against
Georgia Georgia is a really good team
obviously and I like them better than
Alabama right now but you know Notre
Dame going there and I applaud these
schools for playing this game you know
they it's better for college football I
know that you get penalized if you lose
one of these games but I'd like to see
more of this and it's wonderful to have
you know Notre Dame go down there to
Georgia just like Georgia went to South
Bend well and it's going to affect
Georgia a great deal later in the season
even if they win this game they'll
certainly and they are in the playoffs
discussion you know even this early in
the season but at the end of the year
then they actually are going to play
five straight games to end the season
against power five opponents okay now
that's one of the longest you know
consecutive weeks without a buyer
without a group of five opponent without
an FCS opponent that's a pretty long
streak the only thing that makes that
more significant is that if they were to
qualify for and earn their way into the
SEC championship game they would be
having to play what looks like either
LSU or Alabama on a sixth consecutive
week of power five games in that
conference championship game the reason
that this schedule is the way that it is
for Georgia is because of this game
early in the year with Notre Dame so
you've got to give them a lot of credit
because let me tell you what Alabama and
Clemson are not doing this year playing
more than three consecutive weeks
against our five opponents so you know
Georgia should should really be
commended in particular for being right
in the thick of this race and still
scheduling these types of games and
hopefully we can get more of this in the
future talking to Joel Klat part of Fox
Sports college football coverage it'll
be a nooner it's Michigan against
Wisconsin Saturday at noon Eastern on
Fox can clay Hill and it just dripping
out of your voice a nooner I love it
I love it okay I want you to then hype
it up let me hear you do your hunt hey
we're bringing you one of the best if
not the best game of the week no no no
there is you know Joel Jill here you go
you want it I'll give it to you yeah
come on let's go I love this matchup
coming up at noon Eastern on Fox you're
gonna wake up early on the west coast
it'll be worth it because you're gonna
see maybe the best running back in
college football Jim Harbaugh brings
Michigan into Madison
you'll love the atmosphere one of the
best places to see a football game plan
your weekend but watch the pregame show
with urban Rob stone Matt Winer and
Reggie Bush that was good
now you see you thought you were getting
one up on me how do you know I didn't
bait you into doing that for me oh no no
you don't call audibles I saw you a
quarterback
you went to Colorado come on Joel okay
okay and clay Helton win his way into
that job keep that job I don't I don't
think so in large part because I think
he's only still there because the
writing was on the wall for Lynn Swann
to be you know kind of ushered out if
you will even though it's officially
he's kind of stepping away on his own
and what people didn't want in that USC
circle was Lynn making that decision to
you know move in the differ difference
direction from clay and then all
ultimately making the next decision I
think in order they needed a president
which they've gotten that president
needs to focus on hiring an athletic
director and then that athletic director
will likely want their own guy that's
just how athletic directors role you
know you know the average athletic
director stent around the country is
just over four and a half years and it
just so happens that the average college
football coaches coaching life at any
particular school is just over four and
a half years they're directly tied
together so as soon as this new idea is
hired whomever it is I'm almost certain
that they're gonna want to make their
own decision regardless of what happens
during the course of this season and
help me understand
Chip Kelly's logic at UCLA a brilliant
offensive genius at Oregon brought a
little bit of that to the NFL and then
says he doesn't want to run that offense
he ran at Oregon at UCLA is can you tell
me why I I can't and and part of it
here's the thing is I actually when I
was studying what UCLA had in particular
in the offseason I thought boy this does
feel like Oregon a little bit
undermanned in particular at the line of
scrimmage but they've got some speed
that they can get in space a quarterback
that can also exploit that space that's
exactly what Oregon did you know is they
got defenders out in big sections of the
field one on one with very athletic
players and it just seems like that's
what UCLA should be trying to do I don't
understand what's what's going on with
UCLA and by the way behind the scenes
that's not good right now either Dan
because the boosters are
not into you know it's it's like the
nuke LaLoosh deal right you know you
went 20 games you can have mold on your
shower shoes but when you when you win -
everyone just thinks you're sloppy right
like from fumble Bull Durham
well when Chip Kelly is not winning well
then everyone gets upset that he's not
really good with the Boosters and he
doesn't go to a lot of fundraising
events and he's not the greatest
recruiter in the world and everyone
starts to say like hey wait what's going
on when you win ten games or 11 games
everyone's like ah no that's just the
way he does it you know - I brought the
boat so you know behind the scenes there
there are some questions now about Chip
Kelly in particular when you look at Dan
Guerrero their athletic director is
retiring fairly soon so again that ad
coach relationship that's that's a
relationship that will be changing over
in the next year 12 months 15 months at
UCLA I'll leave you with this if if I
told you two years ago Lamar Jackson was
gonna be the hot quarterback this season
the breakout passing quarterback you
would have said what I would have called
you crazy
I would have certainly thought it
would've been Baker Sam darn old but I
tell you what I love what Baltimore has
been doing they've been putting him in a
position to succeed they drafted
specifically for him him with Hollywood
Brown man I got a day that that's such a
good combination because Lamar has
always been a pretty good deep ball
thrower and I think the other elements
of his game are getting much better each
and every week but I got to tell you man
this combination of Hollywood Brown and
Lamar Jackson looks awful dangerous Joel
great to visit with you have fun this
weekend it's must-see TV it's noon
Eastern it's a number contained
Wisconsin number 11 Michigan I love it
thank you
that's a Joel Clint always always good
to have on good sense humor there for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]